- [Voiceover] The Lewis
electron-dot diagram
for C_two H_four is shown
below in the box on the left.
In the box on the right,
complete the Lewis electron-dot diagram
for C_two H_five OH or ethanol,
by drawing in all of the electron pairs.
So as they said, this right over here,
this is the Lewis electron-dot
diagram for ethene
and they want us to fill in all of the,
they want us to draw in all
the electron pairs for ethanol.
And what we could do,
and I'll do it in a way
where we can see which
electron comes from which atom,
but they're not even
asking you to do that.
But in blue, I'm going
to make the electrons
from the hydrogens.
So each hydrogen, you can
think of it as contributing
one electron to each pair,
and that's what's forming
the covalent bonds.
So say this hydrogen is going
to contribute this electron,
this hydrogen can
contribute this electron,
contribute that electron,
this hydrogen can
this hydrogen can contribute this electron
right over there.
And then, let's see.
So now let's think about the carbons.
And if you were actually
taking the EP test,
you wouldn't, probably you
don't even have markers around,
but I'm gonna do it in different colors
just so you can see it.
So each carbon has four valence electrons
that it can contribute
for covalent bonding.
So this carbon over here, that's one, two,
three, and then four.
And now this carbon
over here can contribute
one, two,
three, and four.
And now we think about the oxygen.
So oxygen's interesting.
It's going to have two lone pairs.
So it's gonna have one lone pair.
I can do it there.
One lone pair like that.
And then, it's going to
have, it's going to form
this bond by contributing
one electron to this pair
and one electron to this
pair right over there.
So each of these pairs
represent a covalent bond.
This one I could have
drawn a little bit lower,
but I think you get the idea.
Those, I have drawn in
all of the electron pairs.
And I'll just think about part e.
What is the approximate value
of the carbon-oxygen-hydrogen bond angle
in the ethanol molecule.
So, in the ethanol, they're really saying,
so the ethanol molecule, they
want to know the bond angle.
You have the oxygen bonded to a hydrogen
bonded to the C_two H_five.
So I'll just write that as,
C_two, I'll just write
C_two H_five, like that.
And they want to know
what is approximately
this bond angle going to be.
And the important thing to realize is,
when you form these bonds with
oxygen, it's going to have
pretty close to a tetrahedral shape.
Why? Because the oxygen
has these two lone pairs.
So these two lone pairs are
forming the other parts,
the other, the other,
I guess you could say points
of the tetrahedral shape.
And so if we were
talking about just water,
so, water, if we were talking about
a water molecule right over here,
and I'm not doing a
good job of drawing it.
You could draw one electron pair there
and then the other electron pair
would be here in the back.
Actually, I could, let
me draw it like this.
Let me draw, I could draw it like this.
If we were talking about water,
I could draw one hydrogen popping out.
I could draw the other
hydrogen popping in.
And then one electron pair is over here
and one electron pair is over here.
This bond angle over here in water,
this is, I guess, a semi-useful thing
to know in general.
You could kind of eyeball, and say,
oh that looks like a little bit more
than 100 degrees, and you'd be right.
This is approximately 100
point four point five degrees.
And this is actually not a
perfect tetrahedral shape.
It gets distorted because
these lone pairs of electrons
are repelling each other
and making these two get in
a little bit closer
together with each other.
And if you have a pure tetrahedral shape.
So you have something in he middle.
Well, let me just,
if you had a pure
tetrahedral shape like this.
So let me, so let me draw it like this.
So something popping out.
You have something, something going in.
And then you have two things like this.
That's one way to think
about a tetrahedron.
There's others.
Then the bond angle between all of these
if it's a more, I guess you could say,
symmetric tetra, a
non-distorted tetrahedral shape,
is 109.5 degrees.
And this is a reasonable,
a reasonably useful number to know,
obviously for this question as well.
I don't know if you could,
if this is obvious.
Let me actually draw the tetra-hed,
let me connect the tetrahedron.
So, you could draw it like that,
and then that would be the
other side right there.
I don't know if that helps.
Let me draw another one.
So, if I were to draw a tetrahedron
and if this was transparent,
you have a molecule, or you have an atom
in the middle, and then
you have the four bonds.
One, two, three, four.
I could say four bonds or lone pairs.
Then, let me make sure you
see the one in the center,
then the angle here is
approximately 109.5 degrees.
So this is going to be tetrahedral,
we have these lone pairs
that are going to be repelling
each other a little bit.
So you're going to be
someplace in the neighborhood,
of, I don't know, around where water is
or more pure tetrahedral shape.
So I would say your bond
angle is going to be,
I don't know, between 104 and 110 degrees.
104 to 110 degrees.
In fact, I would, I would estimate
that it's going to be more than 104.5,
because these, well, I just,
I won't try to dig too much into it.
They really just want us to approximate,
approximate the value.
So you could give anything in this range
would be a suitable, suitable answer.